President Trump seems to be standing by
EPA Administrator Scott Pruett despite a
series of concerns that appear to have
put through it's job security in
jeopardy Pruett is fending off repeated
questions over his housing arrangements
staffing decisions and spending as head
of the agency president said yesterday
he still has confidence in through it
Julianna Goldman was first to report on
a long time EPA official who was
reassigned after clashing with Pruit
she's outside the agency's headquarters
in Washington Julian on a good morning
good morning well despite warnings from
White House official Scott Pruett has
launched a full-court press to defend
himself but it's not stopping even some
Republican lawmakers for calling for his
resignation
President Trump praised his embattled
EPA Administrator but expressed some
uncertainty about the barrage of
negative headlines
[Music]
the ethical cloud hanging over Pruitt
keeps getting darker sources tell CBS
News that last year Pruitt asked to use
lights and sirens to get through routine
Washington DC traffic his lead security
agent told him it can only be done in an
emergency less than two weeks later that
agent was reassigned within the agency
as more ethical questions piled up this
week Pruitt went on a media offensive
it's draining the swamp renting an
apartment from the wife of a Washington
lobbyist I don't think that that's even
remotely fair to ask that question
Pruitt rented a condo from lobbyist
Steven Hart for just $50 a night
claiming the arrangement was cleared by
an EPA ethics lawyer that is something
that again has been reviewed by ethics
officials here they've said that its
market rate but that lawyer now says he
didn't have all the facts including that
blewett's daughter also stayed in a room
there mr. hard has no clients that has
business before this agency Pruitt also
claimed the rental didn't pose a
conflict of interest but Senate lobbying
records show Hart represented several
companies who had business with the EPA
while Pruitt was his tenant Pruitt
saving grace may be that President Trump
and conservatives both see Pruitt as
perhaps the most effective cabinet
secretary and rolling back Obama era
regulations but gale this drip drip
really has taken on a life of its own
and the president has been known to
praise someone one day and fire them the
next yes we have seen that Julianna
thank you more than once thanks a lot